um a lot of people do a lot of my
friends do when they um heard i was
becoming a math teacher they said why
maths so much hard work okay it's hard
work to understand some of the ideas
um it's hard to practice some of the
skills and really master them
okay but i want to tell you a secret
okay and in fact i'm going to ask you to
write it down
mathematicians and um we are all
mathematicians people who do math
mathematicians only ever do hard work
because they want to make things
easy yeah i'm not on the board
so it should be in your book let me try
and explain this right because it sounds
weird it sounds unusual it sounds
kind of backwards right mathematicians
work hard because they're lazy
how does that work try and explain
sometimes a problem it looks hard it
looks difficult it looks like it's going
to take a long time
mathematicians i'm trying to work out is
there like a pattern here
there's something i can do with this
problem that will make it a little bit
simpler it'll make it easier to work
with or quicker
or um easier to make less mistakes yes
some type of formula kind of way to do
it yeah that's right so sometimes we
call these formulas
sometimes we call them strategies
there's all kinds of names for these
things
and rounding and estimating are
one of those strategies right they're
kind of two words for the same thing
it's a bit of hard work to wrap your
head around writing in a study the first
time
once you do it it's really helpful so
let me give you an example
okay i'm going to write down a sum for
you i'm going to put together
um a bunch of numbers a list of numbers
and the idea is to add them up so write
this list of numbers with me
here's the problem
okay here's the question
now some of you might look at that and
think oh
i can jump right into saurina just hold
your horses
for a second before we do that this is a
prickly problem right
there's a lot of numbers i mean who
knows what these numbers are they could
be people
or they could be doughnuts i'm i'm
really hungry right now
consumed um they could be it could be
pencils
it could be anything okay there's a lot
of numbers like five numbers on the list
and also they're kind of awkward numbers
they're difficult to work with
like you can see for instance if i add
together just look at the first two
numbers
right if i add these together i'm gonna
have some like carrying tens and
carrying hundreds do you remember that
you've seen that before and that can be
hard it's easy to get that wrong
right so this is a tricky problem this
is tricky yes
yeah that's right like there's just a
whole bunch of things that i don't like
about this problem
okay but that's okay as a mathematician
i look at this i think maybe i can make
this a bit
easier a bit simpler for me okay because
you know
sometimes all the time actually the
exact answer that you want at the end
sometimes the exact answer not that
important okay you just want to get
roughly in the ballpark
and then you can use that information
and go ahead this happens all the time
for instance
if you want to buy the number of
sausages for a barbecue okay you don't
need to go to hbs and say
now how many sausages do you do is it
two
three two point seven here we go two
point seven because
yeah that looks about right yeah okay
how much was you and like get really
really
bit silly just kind of round it off get
to an approximate number
and then i can make sure everyone is fat
right or you know how many
how many hours of youtube can i watch
before my iphone battery dies okay well
you don't have to be exact that's the
minute you can get in the rough ballpark
and then just make sure your phone
doesn't die
okay so that's what we're going to do
with this list of numbers
uh if you have another color that'd be
really handy but if you don't that's all
right
what i want to do with each of these
numbers is i'm going to
round them i'm going to get close to a
number
that rather being icky and odd or
unusual it's just like a simple number
okay so we'll talk a little bit about
the exact process that i go through here
but for now
let's just follow step by step 631
631 has been awkward it's pretty close
it's in the ballpark of 600. do you
agree with that like it's obviously it's
a bit different
but they're roughly the same okay if you
looked at a group of 631 people
and you looked at another group of 600
people he could be hard-pressed i know
i'd be hard-pressed to work out which
group is bigger
okay 600 that's fine
i've got 280 what's a number that's nice
and round that's close to that yeah go
ahead
300 300 perfect you know um i could have
gone up i could have gone down but
that's that's pretty close
okay and it's also great because this
number's a bit smaller
than that but these numbers are a bit
bigger so i'm trying to like even things
out a little bit
okay i'll do the rest of the numbers a
bit quicker i think that um this
51 is very very close to 50.
this 43 is very close to 40
and this last one alright guys help me
what do you think 96 is close to
100 yeah perfect i think that's
outstanding
okay now have a look at this okay this
set of numbers is not exactly equal to
what we got
in the first place obviously i've
changed all the numbers but they're
still pretty close okay
so instead of saying this equals this
i'm going to put i love this i'm going
to put a
wiggly equal sign out the front okay you
guys know what an equal sign means it
means these things are identical
they're the same the wiggly equal sign
means
they're kind of the same the official
name is they're approximately equal
okay in fact let's just write that on
the side here
this means approximately equal
okay so we're in the right ballpark and
now this is marvelous because all these
numbers are quite easy to deal with
okay we can start to put these together
and it's not hard at all
for instance let's go to the next line i
can see three of my numbers
one two three these guys are all in the
hundreds right
don't shout out yet who can put their
hand up and tell me what happens when
you add six hundred
three hundred and one hundred somebody
has the same thing
yeah go ahead yeah a thousand fantastic
because
the first two numbers that's 900 you
bump it up with the last one that's a
thousand so i'll just
write that down first and it was really
easy like within
five seconds almost all of you had your
hands up an easy one to work out
and then what i've got left over is
these pair of numbers right
50 and 40. i think you can all shout out
and tell me that
90. fantastic okay so
very good and likely to think we're
almost done i
have an answer
that's well it's not exact i know it's
not exact but
it's pretty close it's pretty close and
most importantly
it was very quick like we did that we
just talked through it you didn't have
to do any hard like
long division or something like that
done
now just over on the side here
okay now you don't need to write this
part down but i just want you to observe
the process okay
we're not going to add up this thing i'm
going to try and do it exactly just to
see like
how close were we i knew we were kind of
close but how close
so let's try and do it and i'll do it
from left to right i'll do it one step
at a time okay
so look at these okay
i'll do the i'll do the 80 first if i
add 80 to this what do i get
700 and
any tables anyone yeah keegan what do
you reckon um
710 710 is very question
yes 711 because we've got the one in the
end good 711
that's okay good you've got it 711 and
then i'll do the 200.
so 711 plus 200 gives me
yeah 911. so i'm trying to do this one
exactly over here okay um 51-43 that was
not so bad
51-43 the 10's become
they're okay so you're doing the units
which is a four
and then the tens are
five and four which is nine right very
good
and then i've got this last number
hanging off on the end
okay it's not too bad all right let's
keep going
94 plus 96. i can see some friends of 10
in here right what can i use yeah ready
very good hold on 94 plus 96
very close to 200 it's it's really
question 200 isn't it
um let me try and do this step by step
do you want to help me out with the
yeah what do you think um
so this one might become a 100 because
you use the 10 plus 9 and then you have
the 90 that's all left over so
190 it's 190 isn't it
okay last step and i did this one
earlier so i'm just going to tell you
the answer
at least if i get it right this looks me
like that one's going to carry over
that'll be one one
zero one what do you think
yeah yeah yeah pretty good yeah okay all
right
now have a look let's notice two things
number one how close was i
like how far was i off from the answer
i was about i was about 10 off right
like 11 odd okay
that's really close not bad that's the
first thing i want you to notice
the second thing i want you to notice is
man this was hard
like did you notice how hard it was we
got it wrong a couple of times and
that's quite natural
because these numbers are gross that's
what we started with right
so this process here we got there
eventually
we needed all of us we need to double
check the revit
this one quick easy and very very close